[موسيقى]
احدث القطع التي ستنضم قريبا للاسطول
البحري السعوديه سفن القتال الساحلي التي
تنتجها شركه مارتن الامريكيه التي بدات
بالفعل في تدشين السفينه الثانيه من اصل
اربع سفن تعاقدت عليها السعوديه في عام
لعمليات القوات الخاصه ومكافحه الغواصات
في المياه
والصواريخ لدفاع الجوي القريب من طراز رام
116 ومجهزان بمهبط وحظيره لطائرات
هليكوبتر من طراز هوك
[موسيقى]
المتطلبات الخاصه للبحريه السعوديه دفعت
الشركه لتطوير راس خاص بها تحتسمه ام ام
سي وهي عباره عن سفينه
مضاف اليها بعض التعديلات كما ستكون مسلحه
بالصواريخ هاربون المضاده للسفن وايضا
بالصواريخ كام المضاده للطائرات وكذلك
بمدفعين رشاشين عيار 20 مليمتر وبمنصتين
سرعه السفينه الى 30 عقده في الساعه كما
انها تتمتع بخاصيه الشبح ما سيصاعد عمليه
رصدها على شاشات الرادار اضافه الى كونها
مجهزه بمجموعه من المسيرات الجويه
والبحريه لمهام الاستطلاع والانذار المبكر
[موسيقى]